[Music]
we are getting close to healthcare will
come up in the early to mid part of next
year we're gonna have a vote I think we
already have the votes we feel confident
we have the votes I would like very much
to see it be done this year so we won't
go a step further if we get it done
that's a great achievement but don't
forget it took years for the Reagan
administration to get taxes done I'd
been here for nine months a little more
than nine months we need a wall in this
country you know it I know it everybody
knows it we have to have a wall it was a
display only President Trump could put
on this afternoon the president holding
an impromptu press conference with Mitch
McConnell taking about 40 questions in
just over 30 minutes
as you saw there mr. Trump insisting he
will get through his agenda he and the
mid Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell spoke to reporters in the Rose
Garden after their White House meeting
the two insisting there is no bad blood
following some contentious moments
between them after the GOP failed to
pass and Obamacare repeal a relationship
with this gentleman is outstanding has
been outstanding we are working very
hard to get the tax cuts we will
continue to work hard to get the health
care completed I'm gonna be surprising
some people with an economic development
bill later on but I haven't even told
Mitch because I want to focus on tax
cuts and some other things right now we
have the same agenda we've been friends
and acquaintances for a long time we
talk frequently we don't give you a
readout every time we have a
conversation but frequently we talk on
the weekends about the issues that are
before us contrary to what some of you
may have reported we are together
totally on this agenda to move America
forward my Jessie that was some very
serious public display of affection
between the president and the majority
leader I'm saying that they actually do
get along and if they have an agenda and
that they are maybe they're going to
praise in public and criticize in public
in private well they're best friends for
now and so McConnell blows it then
Trump's going to set him on fire but I
think today symbolically that was a real
show of force for the Democrats they
show that they are together and you
and they public ins yeah no show to the
Democrats who the yeah they're showing
the Democrats they are united they are
strong they have the majority and
they're gonna keep the majority this is
also a rallying cry for the Republicans
they need to get their in gear or else
they're gonna be toast in the midterms
and also it really shows the media
totally under control he's got this you
know you can tell trumps and midseason
form here by how crisp the hand gestures
are when they're crisp and they're
energetic and he takes lots of questions
you know he's feeling good about himself
I think he played all the hits he
bragged about the electoral college
victory yeah he dared Hillary to run
again he bashed President Obama he took
credit for the great stock market the
only thing we didn't get was a nickname
for McConnell I would have liked to have
seen that maybe my team itch Eminem some
suggestions but I think he's a closer
the president he's a fourth-quarter guy
it's crunch time he knows it the years
almost out he's all in on tax reform
he's going to punt Dhaka probably may
even punt the border wall funding is
gonna punt Obama care but he must get
tax reform done or it's over one unlike
some White House press briefings where
the same question is asked over and over
again to try to drill down there wasn't
necessarily an order to this press
conference I kind of liked it for how
chaotic it seemed on the press's side
not on the president's side but the
press they are so hungry to ask
questions and he covered all a whole
range of topics from judges he says he's
gonna have an economic development plan
that he announces soon he said they have
the votes right now for health care
reform but they're gonna wait a little
while he talked about Cuba yeah he
talked about the tax reform pieces
Jessie mentioned but also was able to
talk about the fact that he will have an
opiate announcement
they've been waiting on the national
emergency for opiate addiction and he
says these things take time so everybody
has been asking where my paperwork is
and just so you understand it takes a
little bit time for the government to do
that so I don't know really what
midseason fighting form is but I think I
guess I think I get the gist what did
you think well I think this is a you
know I mean this reminds me what
happened on Friday when the chief of
staff John Kelly was sent out and now we
have Mitch McConnell sent out a lot of
this is about
what's going on behind the scenes
witches there's a civil war raging I
mean the Steve Bannon the president's
former top political adviser has said
he's got a war on the GOP establishment
what does he mean by that he's talking
about Congress he's saying that the
Congress is made up of establishment
Republicans who are not backing this
president and he wants their support and
therefore Bannon is going about trying
to throw out Republicans that he
considers insufficiently Trump backers
now you got that plus you've got the
president at war with a leading member
of the Senate bob corker and that hasn't
stopped that guy just went on over the
weekend Dana so you have the president
saying oh you know don't pay any
attention to these people it's not true
what bob corker says is crazy and then
not one member of the Senate including
Mitch McConnell say anything different
and that said though Kimberly bob corker
is actually working with Tom cotton on
the president's Iran deal that they need
to get done so perhaps there's a lot of
the I don't know the relationship
intrigue is not is masking some actual
work that's happening behind the scenes
I'm not positive know about that but
yeah but I think that's a significant
point to make when you see someone like
and you know Tom cotton who's widely
respected in the area of a you know
foreign policy has been a very strong
you know vocal opponent against Iran and
the deal saying that that wasn't an
appropriate wasn't good deal for the
United States so workers working
together with him that's what you want
to see not just the tweet storm but you
want to see actually and he's sweet and
cotton is working with corker to make
that happen
that's what I'm saying so I think that's
very good so that to me is more
indicative of what's going on than
perhaps some tweets here and there and
then I think you know this is a unique
opportunity kind of like reset the
relationship with McConnell and the
president but nothing will make it more
believable than some wins on the board
and they do need to get you know tax
cuts in they do need to have a budget
that fully funds the military because
we're not in the best position since the
Obama years in terms of fully funding
and being combat ready all of these
things are important and the Republicans
need to pick up three to four seats in
the Senate so that they can actually
continue to get legislation through so
that the president won't have this
problem every time getting through his
agenda because it's been a little bit
the slow start you know get the training
wheels off and now they've got to push
it through before we go to talk about
more about the whole band and movement I
do want to just capitalize on this
because Kennedy I know you've been
covering this on your show as well this
is Senator Graham and talking about the
Republicans actually needing to get tax
reform done Mitch McConnell's not our
problem our problem is that we promise
to repeal and replace Obamacare and we
failed we promise to cut taxes and we've
yet to do it if we're successful Mitch
McConnell's fine if we're not we're all
in trouble we lose our majority and I
think President Trump will not get
reelected I believe that people would it
even if tax reform were to fail that all
of a sudden they're going to try to
elect Democrats because they think that
their economic condition would be better
no but I think what Steve Bannon is
hoping is if they elect different kinds
of Republicans because you know the
waste abandon sees that the Republican
Party has to change and there are
ineffective people like Mitch McConnell
in Washington DC who are happy being
complacent and and making excuses like
you know Congress can't be put on a
timeline with excessive expectations but
also if you look at Mitch McConnell
today he looked like a hostage by by
steve bannered who's going after him in
his direct terms as you can possibly
make and you know Bannon on Hannity and
at the Values Voter Summit he's naming
Mitch McConnell and and people who are
in line with McConnell they're the ones
whose heads are on the chopping block
and you know the president has been
tweeting at the Senate Majority Leader
but then he's standing next to the
president who's saying no we're best
friends this is great and Mitch
McConnell has to be very emotional and
confused today he's trying to figure out
who were his friends who are his enemies
who is he fighting against but I think
Lindsey Graham sort of brings it into
focus and the point is don't be
distracted by social media or operatives
who are no longer in the White House do
your job pass the bills do your work
leave the Senate Republicans and get
something done that's good for the
economy and for voters who put you there
well let's listen to what Steve Annan
said over the weekend and then the Trump
McConnell soundbite if you could put
those together it's a season of war
against a GOP establishment we need to
move with urgency
the president united states deserves
respect and deserves their support and
you can come to a stick a microphone and
you can say I am NOT gonna vote for
Mitch McConnell for Majority Leader
Steve's been a friend of mine for a long
time I like Steve a lot Steve is doing
what Steve thinks is the right thing
some of the people that he may be
looking at I'm gonna see if we talk them
out of that because frankly they're
great people
my goal is the leader of the Republican
Party in the Senate is to keep us in the
majority the way you do that is not
complicated you have to nominate people
who can actually win because winners
make policy and losers go home that's my
approach that's the way that's the way
you keep a governing majority so Jesse I
imagine that Mitch McConnell probably
spent a lot of time during the lunch
with President Trump explaining his
position I'm not a big fan of Mitch
McConnell but I thought that statement
by his was dead-on what does he say
winners are in the Senate and losers you
know they go home exactly what did he
rattle off when he talked about all the
losing candidates that the Republicans
nominated for Senate back in the day
Sharron Angle Todd akin some of these
O'Donnell they're flame throwers and
they burst onto the scene through the
primaries by the help of the grassroots
and then they get shredded in the
general and then where's your Senate
seat
oops the Democrats have it so you don't
want to cut your nose off to spite your
face I think that's what he's saying he
wants to stay in the majority and I
don't mind banning trying to primary
guys if you're going to primary people
maybe primary the people that sunk
Obamacare repeal it but that's not the
case with Luther Strait I understand
that and that's the fight that the
Republicans are gonna have to make and
I'm worried about them spending
boatloads of dough on races and seats
that don't really matter when there's
competitive seats as you know there's a
lot of Democratic seats exposed in 2018
Republicans have an opportunity for a
little wiggle room where they could lose
Rand Paul right and still have that slim
majority 51 votes to get there right now
they don't have that opportunity so one
of the things Bannon said over the
weekend at the voters value summit is
we're cutting off your oxygen Mitch
McConnell and what he meant by that was
we're going after Republican donors who
are not
satisfied that the Republican Senate has
not advanced the legislation they're not
particularly Wed to Trump although
Bannon is but they want progress they
want to see something from the
Republican domination of the House and
Senate well to the idea that you go to
Mitch McConnell who said that his job is
to keep repeal a Republican majority and
say I'm cutting off your oxygen or that
is a I mean that's a existential it'll
be interesting to see if President Trump
can bridge these two worlds and for how
long he can do it can you keep the
bannon's happy can he keep the
McConnell's happy so that they can he
can keep his majority to try to get as a
gender through that's actually the
toughest part but that's yeah I don't
think Bama is gonna run his game he's
already he's been on the inside he's
made his like list of who he thinks
needs to go and I think sadly even if
McConnell puts up these wins I think
he's gonna probably try to take him and
others out and we've seen what happens
when Boehner has an idea if that isn't
in a chord with the president ie Luther
strange he's gonna go his way okay
well we're going to